[Música]
revista de prensa hoy miércoles en
directo américa de france 24 ya está
conmigo el estudio rosa pérez masdéu
rosa feliz mañana de miércoles llamó a
abrir esta revista de prensa fijando los
en el discurso anti ucraniano y también
la desnazificación de ucrania presente
en cierta prensa rusa vamos a hablar de
los medios el vemos y él como los calla
plaza buenos días raúl exactamente no
alguna prensada rusa sigue insistiendo
en mantener de esta retórica y
precisamente alexander koch en el arcón
somero ska ya pravda hace referencia a
las declaraciones del presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski en la sede
que dijo que cualquier cesión ante rusia
debería ser aceptada por el pueblo
ucraniano mediante un referéndum y coats
este columnista escribe lo siguiente se
pueden imaginar que la élite nazi del
tercer reich en mayo de 1945 hubiera
decidido celebrar un referendo sobre la
rendición dice yo tampoco pero es lo que
parece la propuesta del jefe del estado
ucraniano
por otro lado védomosti pública que
según dijo peskov portavoz del gobierno
ruso el
75% de los rusos estarían a favor de
esta operación militar especial en
ucrania y que el kremlin reconoce que
hay una minoría rusa que se opone a esta
guerra pero que no deja de ser una
minoría el que quizás alguno de estos
opositores cambie de opinión cuando se
dé cuenta de las mentiras de occidente
rosa por el mismo tiempo la prensa la
prensa occidental asegura según la
inteligencia estadounidense británica
que las tropas rusas tienen serios
problemas de abastecimiento y también
otro muy importante en una guerra la
moral efectivamente esto lo señala el
'new york times' radio radio free europe
y muchos medios de comunicación
occidentales precisamente hoy no estas
informaciones que provendrían sobre todo
del pentágono y que insisten en estos
problemas de logística que estaría
enfrentando pues el ejército ruso como
comentabas problemas de suministros de
alimentos de combustible pero también en
raúl aquí una novedad que se destaca hoy
y esa de falta de equipamiento que les
permita pues
es sobrevivir a estas bajas temperaturas
y que de hecho ya ciertos soldados rusos
estarían teniendo problemas de
congelación y que por este motivo
estarían siendo ocupados evacuados ya de
las zonas de batalla lo que avanzamos
rózsa un análisis de arsenio cuenca en
el orden mundial afirma que putin no es
ni fascista ni comunista en que se basa
ex analista para esto rosa pues bien es
un largo de análisis que intentaremos
resumir básicamente este investigador
señala que más que nada a putin es un
nacionalista conservador e oportunista
que quiere devolver la grandeza a rus ya
sea por el medio que sea dice por un
lado en los 20 años que lleva a vladimir
putin en el poder habría tenido tiempo
de socializar los medios de producción y
de avanzar hacia una sociedad sin clases
dice sí que es verdad que ha recuperado
el control sobre ciertas industrias
clave y que también ha reestablecido la
autoridad del estado sobre los oligarcas
pero al mismo tiempo ha promovido el
crecimiento del capital privado y rusia
no deja de ser un estado final
capitalista corrupto y uno de los más
desiguales de europa también señala que
sí que es verdad que putin considera la
disolución de la unión soviética como
una de las mayores catástrofes políticas
sino la mayor del siglo 20 pero que no
es eso por una nostalgia comunista sino
por este recuerdo soviético de rusia
como gran potencia por otro lado dice
que siempre putin ha sido más pragmático
que ideológico que por un lado su
relación tan estrecha con la iglesia
ortodoxa responde más a una forma de
diferenciarse y atacar occidente en el
plano de los valores y de la moral dice
que sí que es verdad que es ultra
nacionalista y autoritario pero no
fascista pero que sí que cada vez hay en
el kremlin figuras más destacadas de un
carácter muy reaccionario y que esta
crisis no de estas primeras semanas de
ofensiva este fracaso ruso si lo podemos
llamar así están desatando una crisis de
legitimidad de putin tanto interna como
internacional y según este investigador
concluye que puede provocar una
respuesta conservadora virus en el seno
del kremlin mucho mayor de la que
protagonizó el propio putin cuando
sucedió ayer sin ser a una guerra santa
de esta rusa pues esto es lo que
considera pues el patriarca kiril el
jefe de la iglesia ortodoxa una gran
aliado de putin que está apoyando
implícitamente la invasión rusa de
ucrania y es que tal y como señala the
economist pues en rusia el ejército y la
iglesia ortodoxa van de la mano así como
el nacionalismo promovido por vladimir
putin y la fe ortodoxa no y es que dado
que en 2015 según el dato que nos da
este artículo el 71% de los rusos se
identificaban como ortodoxos esta
institución eclesiástica es un
importante instrumento de propaganda y
como decíamos pues el patriarca kiril ha
llegado a considerar que esta guerra es
un trágico conflicto que es parte de una
estrategia geopolítica para debilitar a
rusia no reproduce este discurso de que
rusia no es el agresor sino que hay un
gen y dio contra la población pro rusa
en el donbass y dice la lucha no es sólo
en el plano físico sino en el metafísico
rosa gracias por toda la información de
revista de prensa nos vemos mañana
jueves con más vamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado el día